good morning believe nation today's  messages leave the beaten path over do  you read Hoffman one central thing that  you don't learn as a student is to leave  the beaten path how do you essentially  be the entrepreneur of your own life so  was a student I was like well how do you  get into Stanford how do you get an  Oxford what you do as opposed to  thinking how you actually discover a new  path so short one today the question  that eight today is how did you leave  the beaten path leaving the comments  below I'll join the discussion thank you  guys so much for watching have an  amazing day continue to believe and  let's see you again tomorrow morning for  another shot of an espresso